همم باحدى المدارس الان موجود وتحديدا في
مدينه جده طبعا بما ان جده غير الاختبارات
فيها غير ولكن رغم ان جده غير بجمالها
وحلاوتها وناسه الا انهم الطلاب والطالبات
محرومين لمده اسبوع بسبب الاختبارات طبعا
انا ما استطيع انه انا ادخل لانه همم راح
يكون الصوت عالي شوي ولكن راح اخلي المصور
يدخلوا ياخذنا لقطات على وضع الاختبارات
وكيفيه الاختبارات اللي قامت فيها همم
اداره التعليم في مدينه جده طبعا اكثر من
700,000 طالب وطالبه في محافظه جده او
مدينه جده اليوم يقومون بتاديه اختباراتهم
وسط يعني مراقبه
منسوبي ومنسوبات اداره التعليم سواء
المعلمين او المشرفين او الادارات
التعليميه طبعا ايضا يعني في الجهه الاخرى
يتواجد مدير اداره التعليم في مدينه جده
الساده الدكتور نايف الزارع وكذلك زي ما
يشاهد الان عمليه المراقبه في من قبل
المعلمين والمشرفين في اداره التعليم طبعا
جميع المدارس في السعوديه في نفس الوضع
طبعا هذه المرحله الصعبه اكيد انكم اديتو
عليها وانا عديت عليها وانا اصلا قاعد
داخل الان وانا يدي ترتجف لانه قاعد يعيش
الذكريات اللي كنت اختبر فيها فكانت هذه
بالنسبه للمرحله صعبه اكيد كانت لكم
بالنسبه
عليها بنفس الوقت الامتحانات
في وقت ثاني
يعني حظهم حلو الطلاب
في جميع مدارس في السعوديه راح تكون لمده
اسبوع لاسبوع هذا يعني
يخلص من الاختبار يرجع ياخذنا غفوه اذا
كمل مذاكره وبعدها على اليوم الثاني
اللي تفاجات ايه ان شاء الله ونقول يا رب
اللي تفاجات انه في معظمهم يعني خاصه في
مدينه جده ومعظم الطلاب مع عائلاتهم انهم
طبعا الاسبوع القادم راح يكون مده اسبوع
اجازه فهي فرصه
انهم راح يكونون متواجدين لحضور المباريات
اللي راح تكون الاسبوع القادم لان الاسبوع
اللي بعده ايضا راح يكون هناك عوده
للمدارس في الحصيله المناسبه لهم لحضور
هذه
المباريات والنهائيات سواء في همم قطر او
كذلك مشاهدات هذه الاسبوع القادم طبعا همم
يمكن همم
عمليه همم همم نحاول ان نتواصل او نتكلم
مع الطلاب لكن ممنوعين من همم نتحدث معهم
علشان قاعدين الان يركزون واللي يحك راسه
واللي يحاول يفكر واللي يحاول ما ادري ايش
عادي ايش يفكر هل يفكر في هاجس الورقه
الامامه او في هاجس المنتخب اللي يشجع اول
ايي متحمس يشاهد مباريات
هذه الصوره الان
الكاملهم وصوتي مرتفع ههه
شكرا لك